the president's longtime associate Roger
stone is not ruling out cooperating with
the Russia investigation Stu stone is
due to appear in court in Washington
tomorrow this is after his arrest on
Friday in South Florida he rejects
charges that he lied to Congress
Jeff Begay is the only network
correspondent to speak to stone inside
his Fort Lauderdale home Jeff good
morning good morning Roger stone is
facing up to 45 years behind bars if
he's convicted on all the charges he's
facing including a lying obstruction and
witness tampering I asked him if the
weight of that prison time has him
rethinking whether he'll cooperate with
investigators I'm not going to be
convicted because I am innocent Roger
stone is softening in his approach to
the Special Counsel investigation that
he has in the past called a witch-hunt
you seem to suggest that you were open
to cooperating with a special counsel
well I'm not going to I'm going to tell
the truth no matter what I have no
intention of not telling truth I have
never not told the truth but stone also
slammed the FBI rate of his home Friday
morning this was a show of force and
meant to to intimidate me or intimidate
other witnesses who they want to say
certain things I think the American
people are revolted by it according to
court papers stone spoke to senior Trump
campaign officials about WikiLeaks
future releases of hacked Democratic
Party emails Stone who's been friends
with the president for decades denies
sharing the information with n candidate
Trump on Sunday Republican Senator Marco
Rubio was asked whether working with
WikiLeaks should be a crime I think
certainly if you're wittingly doing it
it should be considered as such I mean
you're participating in the work of a
foreign intelligence agency the
indictment also alleges that stone lied
in his testimony before the House
Intelligence Committee a charged stone a
longtime Republican political operative
denies is there a line you wouldn't
cross to protect a president I'm not
going to lie I'm never going to say
anything that's not truthful under oath
or otherwise that's the line
Stone says that he did not tamper with a
witness nor did he destroy evidence he
also told me that he doesn't know what
to expect when he's arraigned in federal
court tomorrow morning in Washington
John
all right Jeff thank you the key
question is what did the FBI take from
inside the home that that may have been
the purpose of that pre-dawn raid all
the electronic devices that could prove
that he lied to Congress that's right
that's why you don't tell them you're
coming because you don't want anything
to get hidden or flush down something